a Chinese company that has made shoes
for the Ivanka Trump brand denies
allegations of excessive overtime and
low wages the accusations were made by a
watchdog group about a factory in
Dongguan that's in southern China three
activists investigating labor conditions
there have been either arrested or have
disappeared the company says it stopped
making Ivanka Trump brand shoes in March
Ben Tracy is in Beijing with the growing
concern about the fate of the missing
investigators Ben good morning good
morning so these three men were working
for a us-based organization called China
labor watch and this is an organization
that has been investigating for working
conditions here in China for about 17
years now and the leaders of the
organization say they've never seen
Chinese authorities crackdown on them
quite this way and they think it's
because the Trump name is involved the
Ivanka Trump fashion line is all about
style and sophistication that has grown
into a 50 million dollar brand but this
is the other reality some of her shoes
have been made here at the hejian
international shoe factory in Dongguan
China China labor watch says three men
have been investigating poor working
conditions at two of hwachun's factories
since last year and claimed they
documented work days that often lasts
longer than 18 hours for pay less than
China's minimum wage and repeated verbal
abuse now the organization says all
three men have been missing since at
least Sunday the wife of this man hua
hai Fung tells CBS News that the police
have detained her husband and accused
him of illegal surveillance
William Hurst is a professor at
Northwestern University and a board
member of China labor watch this is the
first time that activists are
investigators working in any way in
collaboration with China labor watch
have been detained in this manner China
labor watch has spent nearly two decades
investigating Chinese manufacturing
companies that produce products for US
businesses such as Apple and Disney in
April the organization says it sent a
letter to Ivanka Trump pointing out
their concerns but receive no reply mark
fisher footwear the company that lies
Ivanka Trump's name told CBS News we
were unaware of the allegations and will
look into them immediately Ivanka Trump
is well known here in China especially
after videos of her daughter singing in
Mandarin went viral and her husband
Jared Kushner has been seen as
instrumental in arranging the meeting
between Chinese President Xi and
President Trump in Florida back in April
now China labor watch admits that they
chose this Factory in part because
that's where they make some of Ivanka
Trump shoes they knew they would get
attention for some of the labor issues
they're trying to highlight here in
China we did want to find out from
Ivanka Trump's brand if they continue if
they plan to continue making products
here in China given president Trump's
America first agenda but they did not
respond Gayle
all right Thank You Ben Tracy reporting
from Beijing